oji la totalité et quel plus que la
somme de ses parties cette importante
question est à la base du grand clivage
qui structure la sociologie le holisme
est l'un des deux grands courants issu
de cette rupture ce courant et étudie la
société comme un tout qui est plus que
l'addition des comportements individuels
qui la composent chaque personne est
dépassé par ce tout chaque membre de la
société et donc soumis à des forces
sociales qui détermine les pratiques
individuelles l'autre grand courant
c'est l'individualisme méthodologique
qui perçoit à la société comme la
stricte addition des comportements
individuels les individus ne sont pas
contraints dans leur action et c'est
l'agrégation de tous les comportements
individuels qui forment la société
aujourd'hui cette opposition est
peut-être un peu dépassé mais c'est une
histoire bien trop longue à vous
raconter dans une short de la société
ecc à très bientôt